Hi.
I'm Andres from the
Android NFC team,
and I'm excited be here talking
to you about the great new NFC
and Host Card Emulation
features we've
built for the L
Developer Preview.
First off, let's see what host
card emulation is all about,
and how we're making it even
better in the L Developer
Preview.
In KitKat, we feed the
NFC radio with HCE,
opening up NFC's wonderfully
simple proximity interface
to any developer on any device.
NFC applications
were no longer forced
to run on specialized
and proprietary hardware,
and instead could now
run directly on the CPU.
This enabled apps running
any KitKat or later device
to leverage the capabilities of
the ever-growing NFC ecosystem.
Mass transit, identity,
building access.
These are just the
tip of the iceberg
with what you can
build using HCE.
HCE allows apps on your phone
to look like a smart card,
such as a public
transit or payment card.
Just like an application
running on a smart card,
an HCE app just
needs to register
an application
identifier or AID.
Application identifiers
allow NFC readers
to select the application
they want to talk to.
Our I/O transport
app, for example,
registers the AIDs it's
interested in with the Android
Runtime.
When you tap your phone
on the transport reader,
it selects that AID, and
the I/O transport app
gets invoked automatically.
It's then free to exchange
arbitrary data with the reader.
Based on your feedback, we've
expanded HCE capabilities
to open it up for more use
cases, easier integration,
and broader availability
in the L Developer Preview.
Let's see what's new.
Lots of early HCE
developers noted
that they didn't know their
AID list at compile time.
They wanted a way to
register them dynamically,
depending on the state
of their application.
Starting with the L
Developer Preview,
applications need not
register their AID statically
in the manifest.
Now, applications
can dynamically
register for AIDs they're
interested in at runtime.
For example, if
your loyalty card
receives a new type of loyalty
card with a different AID,
you can register it without
recompiling the app.
Use these APIs to
dynamically register
your application's AIDs.
We're also opening up
the possibility for apps
in the foreground to handle
the transaction, even when they
might not be the default
app for that AID.
In KitKat, you could
only pick one application
that would handle
all of your payments,
forcing the user into Settings
to switch the default.
L Developer Preview
allows your app
to register as the temporary
default for a set of AIDs
when it's in the foreground.
Imagine you have a payment app
that only works in your store.
Call it OneStorePay.
Probably won't be set as
a default payment app.
But if the user opens
your app before she taps,
the transaction is
yours to handle.
The AllStorePay app, which
works in every store,
will work just as
the user expects
when your app isn't
in the foreground.
You've used these APIs to
register your application
for dynamic foreground dispatch.
You can find out more about
how to write HCE apps, as well
as all of our great new
features, right here.
Thanks for giving me the
time to talk to you today.
I hope to see you soon building
great NFC and HCE apps.